sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wünsche
ihnen allen einen schönen guten morgen
die sitzung ist eröffnet
also das war jetzt wirklich ein
vergnügen
vielen dank
bevor wir in die tagesordnung einsteigen
möchte ich aber einen ganz besonderen
gast heute morgen begrüßen auf der
ehrentribüne hat der präsident der werk
hoffner rada der ukraine
stefan
russland tschuldigung russland stefan
tschök platz genommen ich freue mich
sehr dass sie heute hier sind mit der
delegation
[Applaus]
lieber russland ihre erste auslandsreise
nach dem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff russlands
auf irland führt sie nach deutschland
exakt 100 tage nach kriegsbeginn hätte
ich sie und ihre delegation gerne unter
anderen umständen in berlin begrüßt der
beifall hat deutlich gezeigt der
deutsche bundestag steht fest an der
seite der ukraine
wir werden ihr land weiter humanitär und
militärisch finanziell und diplomatisch
nach kräften unterstützen
auch die bürgerinnen und bürger in
deutschland sind solidarisch mit ihrem
land und mit ihnen den geflüchteten die
in unserem land eine heimat gefunden
haben dennoch weiß ich dass sie sich
wünschen sehr schnell wieder in ihre
heimat zurück zu können
nehmen sie diese klare botschaft gerne
auch mit in irland und ich habe auch
gestern als wir gemeinsam auch in den
ausschüssen waren gespürt dass diese
botschaft auch von den kolleginnen und
kollegen aus dem parlament in ihre
richtung ausgesprochen wurde und
diese botschaft möchte ich dass sie das
auch an ihre landsleute weitergeben aber
auch nach kiew nach odessa nach mario
pohl und alle anderen orte die schon so
viel leid und so viel zerstörung gesehen
haben eine souveräne ukraine gehört zu
einem freiheitlich demokratischen europa
irland hat das recht selbst bestimmt
über seinen weg zu entscheiden in
freiheit und frieden
ich danke ihnen allen jetzt gibt es
einen harten bruch weil wird in der tat
jetzt in die tagesordnung einsteigen
müssen